tomorrow it's a a chance that cannot be
missed for the people that are losing
their lives for the principles of
international law for the serenity of a
state and for preserving and restoring
peace in Europe if tomorrow's means to
talks of last chance failed to bring
credible peace and in phase of naked war
of Russia against Ukraine and mountains
of lies and broken promises it will be
the ultimate time to reverse the logic
of persuasion into the logic of
deterrence EU has shown angelic patience
and indulgence and the word angelic
comes from the name Angela but we have
arrived at limits from the position few
long a baton BIA and staff taébem young
and staffed as four hundred few I know
politicians lenders conflict us after
name on the line flows Berkeley Cardin
of the separatist and positive 2 knots
widens Ukraine can see - the politician
virtually he understood song felassan
and a military solution this conflict us
but a snitched came delivering phone
button button itched so and share from
this conflict despite hangs on and
asking Tiber Burton sadly even if a
ceasefire can be agreed tomorrow it's
unlikely in my view to end the conflict
as recently noted by the British Foreign
Secretary Putin is behaving like a 1930s
tyrant and such agreements a merely part
of a dissembling approach to gradually
legitimize territorial gains before
embarking on another round of attacks if
Putin doesn't want to take the olive
branch he will be severely punished
that's the only way because other way we
accept that Ukraine should be crippled
and Ukraine should not be crippled it's
been a movie de
Salafists indeed our fondest ISM fight
in the oka inner nice insertion Felicity
loft our ski gang is but you haven't so
often Godard
that's us yet ina vended some bets oven
gift over here to smile come I know
vended some sh lesterland